du jour appelle la discussion en lecture
définitive de la proposition de loi
maintenant provisoirement un dispositif
de plafonnement de revalorisation de la
variation annuelle des indices locatifs
la parole est à Madame Olivia Grégoire
ministre délégué chargé des petites et
moyennes entreprises du commerce de
l'artisanat et du tourisme
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur
madame la Présidente
monsieur le président de la commission
des affaires économiques monsieur le
rapporteur Cazenave mesdames messieurs
les députés
je vous prie tout d'abord d'excuser mon
collègue Olivier Klein ministre de la
Ville et du logement pour son absence ce
dernier est en mobilisé suite à la
tragédie survenue à Nanterre
vous nous avez néanmoins vu ces
dernières semaines sur le sujet qui va
nous préoccuper aujourd'hui encore vous
savez donc l'importance que nous
accordons conjointement à ce texte qui
doit nous permettre de plafonner
l'indice des loyers commerciaux ainsi
que l'indice de référence des loyers
nous avons démarré l'examen de cette
proposition de loi déposée par le député
Cazenave le 31 mai dernier
peu de choses ont changé depuis lors si
ce n'est que l'INSEE est venu confirmer
le 25 juin dernier
l'augmentation de l'IMC à 6,69% contre
6,29 pour cent en premier trimestre de
l'année qui était le dernier indice dont
nous disposions pour évaluer l'utilité
d'un prolongement du plafonnement que
vous aviez voté ici même en août 2022
pour les PME cette augmentation
significative confirme donc le
gouvernement dans l'idée qu'il convient
de maintenir provisoirement cette
disposition de plafonnement des loyers
l'essentiel des constats nous dressions
déjà le 31 mai sont toujours d'actualité
et confirmés effectivement par les
derniers chiffres publiés depuis la
première lecture
l'inflation ralentit s'établit au mois
de mai à 5,1% sur un an il est néanmoins
trop tôt pour s'enthousiasmer mais au
moins nous pouvons nous baser sur des
projections plus fiables à notre
disposition
et les chiffres démontrent éprouvent
s'il le fallait qu'il nous faut encore
protéger et accompagner nos commerçants
de proximité
qui représente pas moins de 430 000
commerces dans notre pays
malgré le rejet confirmé du Sénat je
sais pouvoir me remettre à votre
responsabilité donc vous avez su faire
preuve tout au long de ce texte en
votant déjà à deux reprises en faveur de
cette propositions de loi qui prend soin
de préserver les équilibres qui exigent
notre aida de droit d'abord en ciblant
les commerçants qui sont les plus
exposés les TPE les PME c'est à dire les
entreprises qui ont les marges les plus
faibles le moins de latitude dans leur
négociation avec les bailleurs en
particulier les foncières ensuite en
bornant cette intervention dans le temps
jusqu'au premier trimestre 2024 enfin en
conservant le taux de 3,5% qui fait
l'objet d'un consensus entre les
différentes parties prenantes si
tantèques les deux premières critères
soient respectés sur ces trois critères
nous agissons avec prudence en matière
d'intervention de l'État sur les
relations contractuelles la
jurisprudence du Conseil
constitutionnelle c'est toujours montré
à cet égard pointilleuse
nous avons eu l'occasion au cours des
précédentes lectures de débattre des
raisons pour laquelle nos marges de
manœuvre étaient forts limitées j'ai dit
et je redis que je suis plus couverte à
une réflexion large sur le bail
commercial j'ai proposé je renouvelle
mon invitation d'y engager toutes les
bonnes volontés en lien bien sûr avec le
Conseil national du commerce
interlocuteur de référence désormais
pour ce type de réflexion en défendant
les petits commerçants nous entendons
aussi défendre les consommateurs et
c'est pourquoi il semble logique
d'assortir l'article 1 de cet article 2
qui permet quant à lui comme vous le
savez mesdames messieurs les députés de
prolonger le dispositif de plafonnement
de l'IRL également mise en place par la
loi portant en mesure d'urgence pour le
pouvoir d'achat votez l'été passé ce
bouclier loyer
à démontrer son efficacité sans se
plafonnement
l'IRL aurait dépassé 6% au deuxième
trimestre 2023 et les loyers du parc
social et du parc privé aurait pu suivre
cette trajectoire très inflationniste
pour épargner à nos concitoyens une
hausse trop brutale de cette dépense
contrainte le gouvernement propose donc
également de maintenir ce dispositif qui
permettra d'éviter des hausses de loyer
de plus de 6% dans le parc privé d'ici à
la fin de l'année 2023 et de plus de 4%
au début de l'année 24 par cette mesure
nous ferons gagner à tous les locataires
du parc privé en moyenne 15 euros au
moins par mois là encore il s'agit d'un
équilibre puisque si nous devons
protéger les locataires nous ne devons
pas pour autant trop fragiliser les
propriétaires dont une forte proportion
je le rappelle sont des propriétaires
modestes malgré ce que certains ces
vertus à nous faire croire
je ne doute pas vous m'expliquerez oui
un jour peut-être je ne doute pas que la
majorité d'entre vous votera dans
quelques minutes en responsabilité la
prolongation de ces deux dispositifs
temporaires et équilibrés avec des
bénéfices directs concrets pour qu'il
représente pour les commerçants et pour
les Français avec Olivier Klein nous
souhaitions enfin remercier l'engagement
du rapporteur Thomas Cazenave qui s'est
saisi avec l'ensemble des groupes de la
majorité de ce texte essentiel
remercier aussi le président de la
commission des affaires économiques
Guillaume kasbariant d'avoir permis son
examen dans des délais rapides
mais aussi aux collaborateurs et aux
administrateurs d'avoir su faire preuve
comme toujours d'adaptation et de
sérieux
au terme de ce processus législatif je
souhaite au nom du gouvernement que la
représentation nationale vote cette
proposition de loi qui apportera une
protection nécessaire à nos concitoyens
locataires comme commerçant je vous
remercie
je vous remercie
la parole la parole est à Monsieur
Thomas Cazeneuve rapporteur de la
commission des affaires économiques
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
des affaires économiques mes chers
collègues après un deuxième rejet de
cette proposition de loi par le Sénat en
nouvelle lecture nous apprêtons à voter
en lecture définitive le prolongement du
plafonnement de l'évolution annuelle de
l'indice de référence et loyers IRL et
de l'indice des locaux commerciaux IMC à
3,5 % jusqu'au premier trimestre 2024
grâce à ce texte nous continuons à
protéger les locataires et les petits
commerçants et artisans de
revalorisation de loyer trop importante
alors que l'inflation demeure élevée
bien qu'en baisse l'indice des prix à la
consommation s'établissait encore à +
5,1% glissement annuel en mai 2023 je me
réjouis que par deux fois déjà
contrairement au Sénat l'Assemblée est
votée en faveur d'une telle protection
je le rappelle l'objet de cette
proposition de loi et on ne peut plus
simple prolonger l'évolution annuelle du
Pla de l'IRL et de l'IMC utilisé pour
revaloriser les loyers des ménages pour
l'un des commerçants pour l'autre à 3,5%
jusqu'au premier trimestre 2024 c'est
une mesure que nous avions adopté
l'année dernière dans la loi pouvoir
d'achat et dont l'efficacité n'est plus
à démontrer sans la mesure du
plafonnement l'IRL aurait dû s'établir à
plus 6,26% au premier trimestre 2023 et
l'INSEE vient de publier ces derniers
chiffres pour l'ISC il s'établirait à
plus 6,69% hors plafonnement sur le même
trimestre
j'espère donc que devant de telles
données plus personne n'a de doute sur
l'opportunité de cette proposition de
loi nous avons choisi l'échéance du
premier trimestre 2024 car elle
cohérente avec les prévisions
d'inflation actuelles qui prévoit un
retour de l'IRL et de l'IMC sous la
barre des 3,5% au deuxième trimestre
2024 en revanche je ne souhaitais
toucher ni au périmètre d'application du
dispositif ni auto de plafonnement sur
lesquels nous avions déjà trouvé un
compromis lors des débats de la loi
pouvoir d'achat je le redis cette
proposition de loi prolonge ce compromis
il est également important de conserver
un dispositif économiquement équilibré
pour qu'il soit juridiquement robuste
notamment au regard du droit de la
propriété de la liberté contractuelle
fortement encadré par la jurisprudence
du Conseil constitutionnel à ceux qui
souhaitaient diminuer le taux de
plafonnement ou geler les loyers comme à
ceux qui souhaitaient étendre le
plafonnement de l'IMC aux ETI voir à
toutes les entreprises alors que nous
l'avions limité au seul PME je rappelle
que les propriétaires subissent aussi
les conséquences de l'inflation qu'un
plafonnement de 3,5% semble être un bon
intermédiaire entre un gel strict d'une
part et des indices locatifs qui se sont
établis dans les faits autour de 6%. que
s'agissant des entreprises il faut aider
celles qui en ont le plus besoin et qui
ne sont pas suffisamment armés pour
renégocier leur beau à l'amiable cette
proposition loi consiste donc simplement
à prolonger un dispositif existant cela
explique également les délais d'examens
très accélérés devant le Parlement je
sais que certains le regrettent mais je
pense que cela ne nous aura pas privé du
débat de fonds que nous avons pu avoir
en première lecture puis en nouvelle
lecture enfin je réaffirme qu'à aucun
moment ce texte n'a eu vocation à être
un texte de réforme structurelle de la
politique du logement alors que le Sénat
est certain d'entre vous ont témoigné de
leur insatisfaction face aux conclusions
du CNR logement s'il est indéniable que
des questions structurales se posent
alors que le pays une crise du logement
il serait paradoxal chers collègues de
refuser le vote de cette proposition de
loi parce qu'elle ne résout pas des
problèmes qu'elle n'a jamais eu vocation
à résoudre et surtout par la même
occasion de mettre locataire artisan et
commerçant en difficulté en leur
refusant le maintien du plafonnement
qu'ils attendent cela revient cela
revient à prendre le risque de laisser
les loyers augmenter de manière
conséquente dans les mois à venir c'est
pourquoi j'espère mes chers collègues
que nous pourrons voter une nouvelle
fois ce texte à une très large majorité
je vous remercie
nous passons à la discussion générale
avec Monsieur
ignaki et chanice pour le groupe
socialiste
bien merci madame la présidente madame
la ministre monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues nous sommes à nouveau amenés à
nous exprimer sur cette proposition de
loi qui ne convient pas à notre groupe
et plus généralement aux autres groupes
de gauche nous avons l'impression de ne
pas avoir été entendu monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le Président de la
Commission oui un gel ou un
plateformement de l'indice de révision
des loyers est nécessaire dans une
période économique particulièrement
difficile combiné à l'une des pires du
logement que traverse notre pays et qui
ne semble pas inquiéter le gouvernement
outre mesure vous avez parlé des
résultats catastrophiques du CNR non un
effort supplémentaire ne peut pas
vraiment être porté par des ménages qui
consacrent déjà leur plus grosse dépense
mensuelles à se loger qui ne pourront
pas accéder à la priorité appropriété
tant le prix de l'immobilier et
déconnecté de leurs revenus et qui
subissent précarité énergétique et mal
logement d'autant que cette augmentation
des loyers s'accompagne de
l'accentuation d'autres charges charges
de l'immeuble chauffage vous n'êtes pas
sans savoir que les tarifs réglementés
du prennent fin dans deux jours et que
cela constitue un risque pour des
millions de Français si les prix
viennent à augmenter à nouveau très
fortement monsieur le rapporteur la
charge façonniste pèse majoritairement
sur le locataire quant aux charges des
bailleurs n'oublions pas que des niches
fiscales leur permettent de bénéficier
d'abattement conséquent sur leur revenu
je pense notamment au régime des frais
réels aux situations exceptionnelles nos
réponses doivent être à la hauteur
rééquilibrer le taux d'effort entre
locataire et bailleur dont je leur
rappelle trois et demi pour cent possède
50% des logements de particulier mais en
location ce chiffre devrait vous
interpeller et ne nous semble pas
représenter un effort incommensurable
cela sur la période couverte par la loi
d'août 2022 et celle à laquelle ce texte
s'appliquerait une augmentation de 7,1%
reviendrait à imposer au locataire
l’équivalent d'un mois de loyer
supplémentaires or tout augmente plus
vite que le revenu déménage cette
escalade des coûts menace aussi notre
tissu économique puisque nos TPE et PME
en ressortent particulièrement fragilisé
un dirigeant sur 10 envisagerait un
arrêt de son activité à cause de la
hausse du prix de l'énergie en cohérence
avec votre soutien affiché et les aides
financières apportées par l'État un
indice des loyers commerciaux plus
contenu était indispensable notre
proposition de compromis était simple
consentir à une nouvelle revalorisation
plafonnée à 2%. soit 5% sur la période
ce qui permettrait aux petits bailleurs
ou prions accédant qui en ont besoin de
couvrir leurs charges mais si nous
devions légiférer en faveur d'une
meilleure qualité de vie pour le plus
grand nombre des Français les loyers
seraient aujourd'hui je les il ne faut
pas sanctionner les propriétaires mais
il ne faut pas sacrifier leur locataire
alors que la rentabilité immobilière
n'est pas menacée et affiche depuis 30
ans de très très bons résultats vos
arguments économiques ne sont pas
recevables tout comme votre crainte
constitutionnelle nous amendements de
replis pouvaient partiellement contenter
notre demande et rassurer vos
appréhensions une augmentation
exceptionnel contenu à 1% ou 2% et j'ai
juridiquement viable notamment
concernant un secteur comme le logement
qui constitue un bien de première
nécessité le logement n'est pas une
marchandise comme une autre encadrant
suffisamment les loyers et le os de
façon à compenser les charges inédites
et imprévues qui pèse sur les foyers la
crise du logement entraîne un risque
fort de bande sociale de la vue du
ministre et les réponses du gouvernement
notamment à la suite du Conseil national
de la refondation sur le logement ne
laisse pas présager une amélioration de
l'accès au logement dans les mois et les
avener à venir monsieur le rapporteur il
fallait à minima ici être collectivement
à la hauteur en abaissant suffisamment
le taux d'évolution plafonné vous avez
balayé nos propositions après un travail
parlementaire et un débat à la hâte on
reviendra pour le consensus et le
compromis pourtant c'était l'occasion de
prendre des mesures concrètes à effet
immédiat pour redonner du souffle au
locataire modeste mais aussi au classe
moyenne
de plus en plus appauvri par le coût des
logements pour rappel le nombre de
ménages à la recherche d'un logement
social a augmenté de 7% en 2022
notamment en zone tendue vous savez ce
sujet qui me tient à cœur des publics
qui initialement ne se tournaient pas
vers ce type de démarche pour toutes ces
raisons et parce que nous pensons qu'il
était possible de faire plus et de faire
mieux pour rééquilibrer la charge de la
crise sur les épaules des ménages le
groupe socialiste de votera pas en
faveur de ce texte je vous remercie je
vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Thibault Bazin
pour le groupe les républicains
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des affaires économiques
monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues nous examinons en dernière
lecture la proposition de loi visant à
maintenir pendant une année
supplémentaire le plafonnement de la
revalorisation annuelle des indices
locatifs face à une inflation
persistante nous partageons l'idée que
les familles et les commerçants doivent
être protégés et accompagnés les députés
les républicains soutiendront donc ces
mesures pour protéger les locataires
face à l'inflation en la votant pour
autant nous regrettons la méthode manque
d'anticipation du gouvernement manque de
concertation approfondi avec les acteurs
manque d'une évaluation sérieuse puisque
notre Parlement est privé d'une étude
d'impact comme l'a dit la présidente de
la commission des affaires économiques
du Sénat Sophie prima vous nous demandez
de voter non seulement à la sauvette
mais aussi à l'aveuglette nous
regrettons surtout qu'il n'y ait pas eu
de recherche et de mise en oeuvre par le
gouvernement de mesure d'accompagnement
des bailleurs bailleurs public comme
privé pour bâtir le dispositif le plus
équilibré possible
la fin d'accompagner également les
bailleurs face à l'inflation et relever
le défi de la transition énergétique il
y a une urgence à agir et il faudra
d'autres mesures que celles prévues par
cette proposition de loi en effet le
dispositif proposé n'est pas suffisant
il faut aussi accompagner les bailleurs
face à l'inflation il la subissent aussi
l'impact du plafonnement de la hausse de
l'indice de révision des loyers pour les
propriétaires a été évalué à un coût de
750 millions d'euros pour 2022 cela
réduit d'autant leur capacité à
réinvestir alors que c'est nécessaire
vous faites fine l'inflation que
subissent aussi de leur côté les
bailleurs bailleurs privés comme socio
petit ou gros loin des idées reçues
c'est bailleurs peuvent être aussi des
propriétaires modestes qui mettent en
location un bien durement acquis et qui
devront par ailleurs faire face à de
coûts travaux énergétiques dans les
prochaines années s'ils veulent
maintenir ce bien dans le parc locatif
ils ont parfois contracté des emprunts
et le coût de la dette comme des travaux
augmente il en va de même pour les taxes
foncières nous ne pouvons pas le nier
car au moment où notre pays est
confronté à une crise du logement qui se
traduit par une demande croissante de
logement à la fois qualitative et
quantitative il faut avoir conscience
que ce plafonnement qui n'est ni plus ni
moins qu'une perte de recettes
potentielle pour les pilleurs va les
contraindre dans leur capacité de
construction et de rénovation par
exemple pour les bailleurs sociaux
l'évolution du taux de livret A de 0,5 à
3% représente un coup de 3,75 milliards
d'euros qui ne sera pas suffisamment
compensé par la hausse ainsi limitée des
loyers et des appels ce qui réduit
d'autant la capacité d'autofinancement
des bailleurs sociaux ne risque-t-on pas
de pousser les bailleurs à reporter des
travaux notamment énergétiques qui
permettrait de baisser les charges des
locataires par la suite attention donc
mes chers collègues à ne pas poursuivre
des objectifs contradictoires ne
risque-t-on pas également de décourager
les investisseurs dans la pierre alors
que si on encourageait davantage la
construction et la rénovation on
augmenterait l'offre de logement ce qui
diminuerait la pression immobilière au
bénéfice des locataires bien sûr l'accès
au crédit joue également il la capacité
financière des acteurs et des règles en
vigueur qu'il conviendrait de modifier
mes chers collègues nous avons besoin de
nouveaux logements nous avons besoin de
logement mis à la location nous avons
besoin de logement rénové et c'est aussi
en soutenant les propriétaires qu'on
soutient les locataires si on veut
éviter une sortie massive de logement
proposé à l'occasion si on veut éviter
une baisse drastique des mises en
chantier il faut rapidement des mesures
fortes au-delà de cette question des
effets non négligeables du plafonnement
de la révision des indices locatifs pour
les bailleurs actuels et futurs je veux
tirer madame la ministre ici la sonnette
d'alarme
vos annonces à la suite du CNR logement
ont profondément déçu les acteurs du
secteur vous ne semblez pas avoir pris
la mesure de la situation du logement en
France le logement étant crise et avec
lui le bâtiment or vous connaissez
l'adage quand le bâtiment va tout va or
avec une crise de l'offre et une crise
de la demande nous allons au devant
d'une crise majeure du logement avec
près de 16 milliards d'activités en
moins l'an prochain et près de 130 000
suppressions d'emplois qui vont avec la
construction est en panne
l'investissement est quasiment à l'arrêt
il est urgent madame la ministre de
prendre des mesures pour renoncer la
construction inciter la vente de
fonciers constructives stimuler
l'investissement Russie les candidats à
l'accession à la propriété les acteurs
du logement vous ont fait des
propositions très concrètes madame la
ministre les dépenses de demain dans le
logement sont des recettes dès le
lendemain des recettes sociales et
fiscales pour les comptes publics mais
surtout ces investissements dans le
logement amélioreront demain le pouvoir
d'achat des locataires en diminuant leur
facture énergétique enfin et c'est bien
là l'essentiel mes chers collègues ces
investissements dans le logement sont
indispensables pour répondre aux besoins
croissants des Français il en va de leur
bien-être et nous sommes réunis ici pour
porter cette aspiration renforcée par la
crise sanitaire puis la crise
énergétique mais chers collègues il nous
reste à nous mobiliser ces prochains
jours c'est un mois par des mesures
concrètes et efficaces des selles cet
été pour re-solvabiliser la demande et
générer davantage d'offres afin
d'apporter des logements en nombre
suffisant et de qualité aux Français il
en va de notre cohésion sociale et
territoriale
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur romain Daubié
pour le groupe démocrate
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le président de la
commission des affaires économiques
Madame le Ministre chers collègues nous
arrivons aujourd'hui au bout de la
navette parlementaire sur un texte
visant à protéger le pouvoir d'achat des
Français nous nous plaçons dans la
continuité de la loi dite pouvoir
d'achat voter ici l'été dernier qui a
instauré une série de mesures
protectrices des ménages et des
entreprises parmi lesquelles le
pafonnement des indices de référence de
loyer dans le détail nous débattons à
présent d'une proposition de loi qui
vise à prolonger le plafonnement de la
variation des taux d'incession des
loyers et plus précisément l'IRL est
l'IMC et donc légitime de s'interroger
quant au bilan de la mesure votée il y a
un an un an afin d'évaluer l'opportunité
de sa reconduction d'autant plus que le
Sénat vient de le rejeter
quel était l'objectif initial il
s'agissait simplement de lutter contre
l'inflation en agissant sur le premier
poste des dépenses des ménages à savoir
le logement et protéger les artisans les
commerçants notre tissu de TPE et de PME
ces dispositions constituent ainsi un
des boucliers anti-inflation mis à
disposition de nos concitoyens tout
comme les bouquets tarifaires sur
l'énergie ou le panier anti-inflation
cher à la ministre Grégoire le texte n'a
donc pas pour objectif de régler
l'ensemble des problèmes liés au
logement à la crise de la construction
ou encore à l’accession la propriété une
grande loi structurelle sera débattue
pour relever ses défis mais tel n'est
pas le sujet du jour oui il faut
favoriser la construction de logements
neufs en étant imaginatif et constructif
oui il faut des acteurs
continue et des actions pour réhabiliter
des logements déjà existants oui madame
le ministre le statut du bail commercial
issu du décret de 53 doit être débattue
mais non cette proposition de loi n'a
pas pour objet une fois de plus de
résoudre toutes les difficultés de la
construction et du Logement cela n'a
jamais été présenté comme cela feindre
de ne pas trouver toutes les réponses
relèvent d'une grande mauvaise foi
quelle est la vie des experts sur ces
mesures de blocage à titre d'exemple
voilà une analyse objective ce
dispositif je cite mis en place depuis
un an à incontestablement protéger
locataire d'une explosion des loyers
soutenue par l'inflation la 13 est
sérieuse étude de l'observateur clameur
a les mêmes conclusions et nous explique
c'est un organisme de référence que
qu'il évalue à 1,3 l'augmentation
moyenne des loyers en 2022 ce qui
correspond à la moyenne des années
précédentes pendant lesquelles
l'inflation était pourtant bien moindre
sans dispositif les loyers auraient pu
augmenter de plus de 6% comme cela a été
expliqué et rappelé par le rapporteur
Cazeneuve il y a quelques minutes
non il ne s'agit pas de voter en
catimini une augmentation de 7,1% des
loyers comme cela a été affirmé à la
radio par une élue et relayée avec une
mauvaise foi consternante par des
députés tiktokers non nous de débattons
pas d'une mesure néolibérale favorisant
les sociétés foncières immobilières côté
en bourse ni d'une augmentation
automatique de 3,5% des loyers c'est
bien une mesure d'équilibre qui plafonne
les loyers à 3,5%. tout comme les
experts indépendants les députés du
groupe des modes crades considèrent que
ce dispositif a fait ses preuves nous
sommes conscients de l'inflation et des
pressions économiques auxquelles le pays
est confronté mais nous sommes résolus à
agir pour protéger les intérêts des
citoyens et l'économie nationale
pour finir j'invite chacun à prendre ses
responsabilités le droit consignel ne
permet pas de bloquer totalement les
loyers car s'il s'agirait d'une atteinte
évidente à l'article 17 de la
Déclaration des Droits de l'Homme du 26
août 1789 il s'agira également d'une
injustice envers les nombreuses
personnes comme des retraités qui
comptent sur un loyer pour compléter
leur retraite ou encore des bailleurs
privés qui logent des millions de
personnes et s'apprête à engager des
travaux de rénovation je vous rappelle
aussi mes chers collègues que le temps
presse le 30 juin à minuit si aucune
nouvelle loi n'est entra en vigueur
l'augmentation des loyers nos plafond
n'est reprendra en d'autres termes ce
qui prétendent défendre aujourd'hui le
pouvoir d'achat des Français en
s'opposant à ce texte devront endosser
la lourde responsabilité du retour des
loyers des plafonnés mettre en
difficulté locataire tendu parc privé
que du parc conventionné et les
commerçants relèveraient d'une rare
irresponsabilité oui il faut agir
concrètement oui il faut protéger et
accompagner les familles les artisans
les commerçants et les paiements face au
Pic d'inflation oui il faut voter ce
texte je vous remercie
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Daniel Simonet
pour le groupe la France insoumise
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur président de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur les
Françaises et les Français subissent une
crise du logement sans précédent et que
fait le gouvernement en un an il
criminalise les victimes de cette crise
du logement par la loi kasbien et il
impose deux augmentations de loyer à
moins d'un an d'intervalles de 3,5%
chacune soit plus de
7,1%. et durant le quinquennat précédent
c'est si le vol de 5 euros d'APL et
l'appauvrissement des bailleurs sociaux
par la réduction de loyers de solidarité
sachez que nous avons engagé un recours
devant le Conseil constitutionnel contre
votre atteinte au droit au logement j'y
reviendrai par la suite et bien
évidemment nous voterons contre ce texte
intitulé maintient provisoire d'un
dispositif de plafonnement de
revalorisation de la variation annuelle
des indices locatifs que les locataires
artisans et commerçants qui nous
écoutent comprennent bien vous allez
devoir payer encore plus cher non vous
n'étiez pas contraint de faire cette loi
ou bien faire soit faire cette loi soit
laisser s'envoler plus encore les
augmentations de loyer c'est ce que vous
avez osé marteler tout au long du débat
le gouvernement certes activement et on
pourrait s'étonner de son amateurisme au
passage à réaliser qu'il fallait
renouveler l'encadrement voté l'été
dernier laupes en s'opposant à ces
nouvelles hausses serait irresponsable
car si cette loi n'était pas votée alors
locataire artisan et commerçant pourrait
subir des hausses bien plus fortes
mensonge mensonge vous avez rejeté tous
nos amendements tous portant sur un gel
du loyer tout comme nos amendements de
replis pour un IRL à 1%. non vous ne
défendez pas les petits propriétaires
par cette loi votre obsession est de
préserver la rente et les privilèges des
multiples propriétaires en faisant
croire que vous vous préoccupez des
petits propriétaires en faisant croire
seulement car personne n'est dupe 50%
des logements à la location sont la
propriété de 3,5% des ménages et pour
les locaux commerciaux c'est bien pire
encore la réalité avec l'inflation tout
augmente sauf les salaires loyer plus
charges c'est entre 50 et 300 euros de
plus par mois que les familles ont à
payer dans ma circonscription dans quel
mystérieuse région vivez-vous pour ne
pas avoir eu le vent de cette terrible
réalité les locataires sont pris à la
gorge et les situations d'impayés
explosent pourtant même si la part des
loyers dans la consommation des ménages
a été très fortement augmentée c'est la
première dépense que les familles
assurent payer le loyer payer le loyer
quitte à renoncer aux vacances à ne plus
remplir le frigo annuler les rendez-vous
chez le médecin ou chez le dentiste mais
payer le loyer payer le loyer pour ne
pas se faire expulser ne pas
complètement dégringoler et face à ce
problème majeur le Conseil national le
CNR logement devait apporter des
réponses or les réponses les annonces du
gouvernement qui en ont découlé sont si
peu ambitieuses avec une baisse de
budget sans aucune prise en compte de
l'urgence de la situation qu'elle nous
réussit qu'à faire l'unanimité
des promoteurs immobiliers à la
Fondation Abbé Pierre en passant par la
Fédération des bailleurs sociaux on en
attendait rien mais on est quand même
déçu les boulangers comme nombre de
petits commerçants et d'artisans ne s'en
sortent plus et les fermetures
s'accumulent dans le commerce faillite
et licenciement en masse mais vous
n'entendez rien non plus et qui soutient
le gouvernement dans cette défense de la
rente et bien le groupe LR et le groupe
RN oui le RN qui n'aura pas une pour
venir à la rescousse du pouvoir contre
les locataires contre les petits
commerçants vous avez voté aussi contre
le gel des loyers et les petits
propriétaires dans tout ça si le loyer
n'est pas payé vous n'avez voulu
reprendre aucune de nos propositions
dans le débat sur la loi kasbarians
comme dans celui que nous clôturons
aujourd'hui sur l'IRL à 3,5 je le
réaffirme ici l'instauration d'une
garantie universelle des loyers et la
meilleure des réponses pour défendre les
droits des locataires lutter contre les
expulsions tout en préservant les droits
des propriétaires plus globalement
ceux qui nous opposent et la conception
même du logement pour vous c'est un
produit comme un autre sur l'étale du
banquier pour nous c'est un droit à
valeur constitutionnelle prévue dans le
préambule de la constitution de 46 un
principe à valeur constitutionnelle de
sauvegarde de la dignité humaine inscrit
dans la constitution de 58 et dans la
Déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen de 1789 voilà pourquoi nous
faisons un recours devant le Conseil
constitutionnel contre la gloire gaz
variant qui ne vise qu'à faciliter les
expulsions locatives et criminaliser les
victimes de la crise du logement que
voulez-vous ne faites qu'aggraver par
votre politique et par deux faites
l'augmentation des loyers que ce vote
s'il ne s'inverse pas va provoquer le
logement doit enfin être considéré comme
un bien commun et le droit au logement
doit l'emporter sur le droit de spéculer
sur le logement
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Luc Lamirault
pour le groupe horizon
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur le rapporteur monsieur
le président de la commission des
affaires économiques mes chers collègues
nous nous retrouvons pour la lecture
définitive de la proposition de loi
maintenant provisoirement et un
dispositif de plafonnement de
revalorisation de la variation annuelle
des indices les indices locatifs pardon
l'objectif est donc de maintenir le
dispositif de plafonnement de l'indice
des loyers commerciaux et celui de
l'indice et références des loyers mis en
place pour une durée de 1 an par les
articles 12 et 14 de la loi dite pouvoir
d'achat du 16 août dernier jusqu'au
premier trimestre de l'année 2024
comme de la lors de la première lecture
nos collègues sénateurs ont rejeté les
articles du texte je regrette à nouveau
que nous n'ayons pas pu trouver un
accord en effet s'il est vrai que nous
n'avons pas légiférer dès le mois de
janvier ou de février comme l'aurait
souhaité les sénateurs nous n'aurions
pas pu travailler ensemble sur ce texte
et à posteriori sur un texte plus global
prenant en considération toutes les
problématiques liées au logement sur
notre territoire
mais aujourd'hui nous ne pouvons pas
attendre en effet le plafonnement voté à
l'été dernier avec la loi dit de pouvoir
d'achat arrive à son terme en tenant
compte de la persistance de l'inflation
et des prévisions de l'Insee en la
matière pour les prochains trimestres
nous devons nous devons d'agir
rapidement car si nous ne le faisons pas
les loyers pourraient augmenter de plus
de 6% dans le parc privé d'ici la fin de
l'année 2023 et de plus de 4% au début
de l'année 2024
dans l'immédiat plafonné à 3,5%
l'augmentation des indices de loyer
commerciaux et celle de l'indice de
référence des loyers pour les ménages
est une nécessité afin de protéger le
pouvoir d'achat des ménages et la santé
économique de nos commerces car oui cela
permet de les protéger et non pas de
favoriser une hausse des loyers au
profit des propriétaires comme certains
ont pu le dire si ce plafonnement
n'avait pas été mis en place l'indice de
référence des loyers basé sur l'indice
des prix à la consommation aurait pu
augmenter d'au moins 6% en juillet 2022
et augmenterait une nouvelle fois de 6%
en juillet 2023 ce qui fait 12%
à comparer aux 7% qui nous sont opposés
de temps en temps et pas 7 à opposé à 6
je réitère mon souhait madame la
ministre de mener une réflexion sur
l'indice des loyers commerciaux en effet
il s'agit d'un indicateur national qui
ne correspond pas toujours à la
situation de certaines de nos petites
villes et de l'évolution du commerce en
centre-ville est-il normal d'avoir le
même 10 à Paris et à Nogent-le-Rotrou
dans le cadre du Conseil national du
commerce il semblerait judicieux
d'envisager une territorialisation de ce
dernier cela permettrait ainsi de faire
davantage refléter la réalité de nos
territoires et ainsi se soutenir les
commerces de nos centres bourg
soucieux de défendre nos petites
entreprises et nos concitoyens le groupe
horizon et apparenté réitèrent sont
total soutien à cette proposition de loi
je vous remercie
[Musique]
la parole est à Madame Cyrielle
châtelain pour le groupe écologiste
merci madame la Présidente alors que
nous nous retrouvons pour cette lecture
définitive il faudrait que nous
puissions avoir un débat en toute
sincérité devant nos concitoyens moi je
vous le dis bas les masques il faut
arrêter de faire croire que cette loi
est une loi de protection sociale
elle va de fait contribuer à resserrer
les taux financières sur de trop
nombreuses familles qui souffrent de
l'inflation et je vous propose quand
même de regarder les causes de cette
inflation alors ça va étendre un peu le
spectre de cette assemblée mais quand on
dit qu'il est juste de faire peser plus
3,5% d'augmentation de loyer sur les
locataires il est quand même intéressant
de regarder au final qui a contribué à
l'emballement des prix et de voir que le
FMI a publié il y a deux jours une étude
et je pense que vous ne pouvez pas
soupçonner le FMI d'être une proximité
idéologique avec avec la nups mais donc
cette étude nous apprend que dans la
zone euro c'est la hausse des profits
des grandes entreprises qui a été le
principal contributeur de l'inflation de
ces deux dernières années oui il y a eu
la guerre en Ukraine oui il y a eu une
augmentation des prix de l'énergie mais
ces deux dernières années c'est
pratiquement la moitié de la hausse des
prix qui est allée directement nourrir
les profits et les dividendes
donc quand on connaît ça comme on dit
aujourd'hui que plus 3,5% sur les
locataires c'est une mesure de justice
sociale ce rapport vient confirmer les
multiples alertes notamment portées par
Oxfam sur la l'hyperconcentration des
richesses et l'enrichissement indécent
des milliardaires pendant ce temps les
salaires et le pouvoir d'achat ont
sévèrement régressé dans une étude de la
DARES on montre qu'en 2022 les salaires
de base ont progressé moins vite que
l'inflation en neuroconstant le salaire
mensuel de base pour l'ensemble des
salaires du privé a baissé de 2,2%
moyenne ça veut dire moins 2,2% moyenne
quand on prend en compte la fonction et
plus 3,5 en termes de loyer ce n'est pas
tenable cette aspectif financière les
hausses des loyers contribuent fortement
la hausse de 3,5% des 2022 pèse déjà
lourd sur le budget des ménages
on le sait nos compatriotes ont déjà
amené faire des arbitrages difficiles
dans leur budget et ils sont prisonniers
de la dépense des loyers aujourd'hui on
a bien de trop nombreuses personnes
qu'on fasse un 3 arbitrer on te payer
leur loyer ou finalement leurs achats du
quotidien ou supermarché votre politique
est en train de fracturer socialement de
pays et vous restez finalement sourd un
ensemble de crites détresse de personnes
qui nous disent non plus aujourd'hui il
faut savoir les entendre et je vous le
dis je crains que malheureusement la
politique que vous êtes en train de
mener et d'essais qu'elle durable on en
a parlé bien sûr sur les retraites mais
je vous le dis sur la politique du
logement ce que vous faites depuis
maintenant des années aura un impact
extrêmement durable parce que c'est
chaque mois que de nombreux non
concitoyens peuvent se demander comment
ils feront pour payer leur loyer ou
leurs factures d'énergie et donc je ne
peux m'empêcher de rappeler quand même
la longue liste des erreurs que vous
avez faites parce que ces erreurs là
aujourd'hui les Français le paient tous
les jours ces erreurs ont commencé par
la baisse de des aPL elles ont continué
quand vous avez décidé de réduire les
APL des locataires du logement social
demandant au bailleur HLM de finalement
compenser cette baisse des appels vous
le savez le budget des logements sociaux
des bailleurs sociaux c'est
principalement payé par les locataires
du logement social votre politique et
donc extrêmement clair quand vous devez
réduire les dépenses vous le réduisez et
vous prenez l'argent au plus pauvre des
Français la deuxième erreur est quand
même l'ouverture de ce quinquennat si on
peut dire en beauté sur le logement de
votre part c'est la loi de casse variant
c'est-à-dire que alors qu'on a une crise
du logement
catastrophique votre seule réponse c'est
des amendes et la prison
non mais c'est nous nous protégeons
toute personne nous le disons et nous
l'avons dit nous professons toute
personne qui cherche un toit nous
pensons que le droit au logement est un
droit fondamental que de droit d'avoir
un chez soi d'avoir un lieu pour
protéger son intimité pour pouvoir
mettre sa famille que leurs enfants
puissent grandir que leurs enfants
puissent faire leurs devoirs de manière
tranquille sans se demander s'ils auront
froid s'ils auront faim s'ils vont mal
dormir ce que vous savez par exemple
vous nous parlez de réussite scolaire
mais comment est-ce que vous voulez
qu'on réussisse de manière scolaire
quand en fait on a mal dormi qu'on a
dormi dans une voiture donc on a dormi
dans une chambre d'hôtel surpeuplée
c'est celle la réalité sur les questions
du logement
c'est ça
le dernier votre avant-dernière en date
c'est finalement le CNR du logement on
aurait pu dire bon ils ont pendant cinq
ans ils ont fait n'importe quoi mais
cette fois-ci ils ont compris réunissent
tout le monde ils les font travailler
pendant des mois avec des propositions
qui sont mesurées qui sont applicables
qu'est-ce que vous en faites on a
l'impression que vous les avez mis à la
poubelle ce n'est pas respectueux du
travail qui était engagé ce n'est pas
respectueux de l'attente des Français ce
n'est pas respectueuse de cet assemblée
de ne pas nous permettre d'en discuter
donc aujourd'hui oui c'est une nouvelle
erreur et enfin la dernière erreur vous
allez la faire aujourd'hui vous allez la
faire aujourd'hui en continuant à voter
info bouclier social nous vous l'avons
dit le gel des loyers ou à minima la
proposition d'augmentation de 1% un
minimal à proposition d'augmentation de
1%, merci nous continuerons à voter
résolument contre
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Monsieur Stéphane peu
pour le groupe gauche-démocrate et
républicaine
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
des affaires économiques monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues une fois
encore la préparation et la
précipitation gouvernementale nous
conduise à prolonger dans l'urgence sans
consultation sérieuse sans études
d'impact et même sans évaluation
un dispositif qui est une très mauvaise
réponse à une vraie question
notre pays connaît une crise
considérable du pouvoir d'achat crise
qui frappe d'abord les foyers les plus
modestes puisqu'elles résulte de l'écart
entre les niveaux des salaires et des
pensions d'une part et l'explosion des
prix d'autre part c'est dans ce contexte
de très grande tension sociale
que vous nous proposez d'autoriser une
nouvelle hausse après celle de l'an
dernier de 3,5% des loyers ceux des
particuliers comme ceux des petites
entreprises votre proposition n'est donc
pas un bouclier tarifaire mais en
réalité une véritable courroie de
transmission inflationniste au détriment
des familles modestes vous prétendez que
ce dispositif constituerait un point
d'équilibre entre la protection des
bailleurs et celle des locataires alors
même qu'il ne subissent pas de façon
équilibrée les conséquences de
l'inflation en effet vous négligez le
fait que l'essentiel des hausses
intervenus ces derniers mois et celui
supporté par les locataires ceux du parc
privé comme ceux du parc social par
l'intermédiaire des charges qui sont
directement reportées sur leur quittance
de loyer en particulier l'électricité
mais aussi le gaz qui a augmenté de 68%
en 2 ans et donc en plus les tarifs vont
être déréglementés à partir du 1er
juillet prochain donc au moment même où
ils doivent affronter une explosion de
ces charges vous condamnez à une
véritable double peine ces jeunes ces
travailleurs de la première ligne s'est
retraités tous ces foyers modestes pour
lesquels le logement constitue deux très
loin la principale dépense alors bien
sûr vous aurez beau jeu de nous faire
remarquer que la majorité des sénateurs
entendaient porter à 6% ce faux plafond
nous échapperions ainsi au pire
décidément pas plus que vous ne semblez
mesurer les conséquences dramatiques du
nouvel hausse des loyers sur les
familles modestes elles dans le pouvoir
d'achat c'est le plus douloureusement
effondré en deux ans elles qui ont vu
leur passer leur loyer augmenter elle
qui ont déjà vu leurs APL être rognés
mes chers collègues dans cette situation
d'une exceptionnelle gravité notre
proposition n'est pas acceptable et à la
place nous vous faisons une double
proposition enfin vous nous refaisons
une double proposition d'autre part il
faut répondre à l'urgence pour cela il
faut un gel des loyers c'est la seule
vér Miss sous protection possible quand
quelqu'un se noie on lui sort la tête de
l'eau on ne discute pas pour savoir à
quelle profondeur on doit le laisser se
noyer d'autre part votre solide situe à
l'égard des bailleurs ne dure que tant
qu'elle vous permet de reporter sur les
locataires les efforts sur les loyers et
les charges si vous voulez enfin prendre
en compte les difficultés des bailleurs
compensées auprès d'eux le gel des
loyers que nous proposons et quoi qu'il
en soit modifié le calcul de l'indice
locatif de l'indice locatif pour le
décor est né de l'inflation l'autre
niveau de réponse c'est tout simplement
de retrouver une politique du logement
dans ce pays car la situation que nous
connaissons dans ce domaine ne résulte
ni de la guerre en Ukraine ni des
conséquences de la crise climatique
c'est bien vos choix politiques qui sont
en cause avec pour conséquence
l'effondrement de la production et l'axe
fixie des organismes HLM et les réponses
apportées aux propositions du Conseil
national de la Fondation consacrée au
logement ont déçu tous les acteurs du
secteur privé du secteur public
eux qui s'étaient pourtant réunis
pendant plusieurs mois pour essayer de
formuler des propositions raisonnables
vous auriez pu par exemple au moins
supprimer la RLS aux effets désastreux
sur les capacités de financement des
organismes HLM baisser la TVA sur la
construction du logement social qui est
évidemment à nos yeux un bien de
première nécessité telle serait en
réalité les choix d'un gouvernement
conséquent
qu'un gouvernement conséquent devrait
faire pour relancer la construction de
logements abordable dans notre pays mais
d'ici là compte tenu de nos observations
et des conditions anormales mais
désormais coutumières coutumières
d'examen de ce texte nous nous
prononcerons bien sûr contre ce texte
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Louis
Bricout pour le groupe libertindépendant
outre-mer et territoire
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur la ministre mes chers
collègues plus de 12 millions de
personnes fragilisées par rapport au
logement plus de 4 millions de personnes
mal logées dans ce rapport annuel sur
l'état du mal logement en France
présenté en début d'année la Fondation
Abbé Pierre s'inquiétait une nouvelle
fois des fragilités accrues je cite lié
je cite aux insuffisances du
gouvernement il faut dire que depuis 6
ans vous avez fait le choix d'une
politique fiscale et budgétaire qui
tourne le dos à la redistribution il
faut dire que lorsqu'il a fallu faire le
choix du quoi qu'il en coûte vous n'avez
pas traité de façon équitable les
Français dans le même temps les prix
commençaient à flamber pour atteindre
des niveaux qu'on leur connaît les
dépenses incorporessibles explosées
précipitant chaque jour plus de familles
dans la précarité en 6 ans le logement
est passé de moins d'un quart des
dépenses 22% pour les ménages modestes
après d'un tiers 31% et il ne s'agit
malheureusement que d'une moyenne
derrière les chiffres il y a une réalité
humaine de moins en moins insupportable
de moins en moins insupportable pour qui
la vie et naturellement pour nous aussi
car de la même façon que le fondateur du
Mouvement Emmaüs s'appelait à une
insurrection de la bonté il nous faut 70
ans après créer les conditions d'une
révolution de l'équité oui comme j'ai
déjà une occasion de le dire il est
insupportable de voir de plus en plus de
nos concitoyens de venir vulnérable
vulnérable en raison de revenus trop
faibles vulnérables lorsqu'ils se sont
acquittés du prix des loyers des charges
courantes ou d'électricité alors oui les
députés du groupe iode voteront le
bouclier loyer pour contenir
effectivement cette augmentation un vote
faute de mieux conscient que pour ceux
qui vivent des fans difficiles
3,5% de plus c'est 3,5 % de trop
un vote par défaut parce que votre
proposition est une solution partielle
et de court terme préparé à la
malheureusement notre conviction
profonde que vous devriez partager par
des choix et des actes surtout c'est
qu'il nous faut déployer une politique
de l'habitat fondée sur le bien logé
pour toutes et tous pour la France du
21e siècle il était un devoir qui
s'impose à nous que chacun chacune
puisse avoir un logement digne et un
coût supportable allongement dans les
charges soit contenu par un reste à
vivre descend des ménages y compris les
plus modestes un logement d'abord
responsable avec un vrai accompagnement
social lorsqu'il y a besoin une
transition
énergétique une adaptation
vieillissement ou handicap lorsque c'est
une nécessité
ça veut dire mes chers collègues qu'il
faudra aller plus loin que les
propositions de madame la Première
ministre suite au cnr-logement pour
produire suffisamment de logements à
loyer abordable pour aider véritablement
et durablement les locataires fragilisés
notamment en revalorisant et en
élargissant les APL se faisait partie de
nos propositions pour en finir avec
l'habitat dégradé et avec la précarité
énergétique sur le sujet que vous le
savez sur ce sujet vous le savez nous
devrons pas nous passer d'un vrai plan
pluriel permettant de massifier les
rénovations vous l'aurez compris au
groupe yote nous voulons sortir du
provisoire pour nous inscrire dans de
vrais trajectoires parce que j'ai eu
l'occasion d'intervenir à de nombreuses
reprises sur le sujet je ne reviendrai
pas sur les rendez-vous manqués du choc
de l'offre c'était pourtant une promesse
du président de la République mais dans
les faits pour l'interrogation mesurent
recyclage et rabotage d'anciens
dispositifs construction neuve en chute
libre baisse et dépenses d'entretien et
rénovation entravés par les logements
sociaux
pour ce qui est de l'immobilier
d'entreprise vous avez fait le choix de
protéger mieux les propriétaires
investisseurs une décision qui risque
peut-être en tout cas j'espère pas de
fragiliser notre tissu économique au
final vous nous proposez une mesure
provisoire qui évite le pire mais qui
pour autant impactent les plus modestes
les plus précaires sans être pour tenir
compte obtenir compte du contexte
d'inflation et de ses effets cumulatifs
sur le pouvoir d'achat comme je l'ai dit
dans mon propos liminaire nous
regrettons une absence de vision de long
terme sur les politiques du logement
monsieur le ministre notre vote nous
engage collectivement nous retrouver
autour du projet de loi de finances pour
nous donner enfin les moyens de
politique beaucoup plus volontariste
certes les enjeux autour du logement
sont évidemment d'ordre économique et
écologique mais ils sont aussi
évidemment sociaux comme le disait
d'ailleurs Jean-Baptiste André Godin au
19e siècle le logement c'est la base du
progrès social je vous remercie
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Bastien
marcho naissance
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le Président le commission
monsieur le rapporteur chers collègues
depuis plusieurs mois le contexte
géopolitique international bouleverse
notre économie et malheureusement le
logement n'y fait pas exception
si la France tient bon nous avons
collectivement été contraint d'assister
à des hauts successives des prix de
l'énergie des matériaux ou encore des
taux d'intérêt autant d'éléments qui
sont venus renchérir le coût du logement
pour nos concitoyens qu'ils soient
locataires ou souhaitent accéder à la
propriété depuis la gare en Ukraine
l'inflation a donc fait son grand retour
face à cela nous avons Fuchu nous avons
su faire preuve d'une mobilisation sans
faille en adoptant délété dernier des
mesures d'urgence pour la protection du
pouvoir d'achat indemnité carburant
revalorisation des minima sociaux des
bourses ou du point d'indice pour les
agents publics pérennisation de la prime
de partage de la valeur ou encore la
baisse des impôts
autant de mesures qui font
qu'aujourd'hui la France à l'inflation
la plus faible d'Europe
et parce que le logement reste le
premier poste de dépenses nous faisions
déjà il y a un an le choix de la
revalorisation des aPL et du
plafonnement de la hausse des loyers à
hauteur de 3,5% maximum
grâce à ce plafonnement c'est une hausse
potentielle de 6,3% des loyers qui a été
empêché cela représente en moyenne un
gain de pouvoir d'achat de plus de 200
euros par an une vraie mesure de justice
sociale donc dont les premiers
bénéficiaires ont été les plus modestes
de la même manière nos commerçants et
petits entreprises qui font vivre des
millions de Français garantissent le
dynamisme du tissu économique de
proximité n'ont pas été oubliés puisque
aussi ont pu bénéficier de cette mesure
d'encadrement
un an après forcée de constater que si
l'inflation faiblit elle persiste la
pression sur les loyers reste forte et
la hausse des taux d'intérêt en rendant
plus difficile l'accès à la propriété
contribue mécaniquement à augmenter le
nombre de personnes dans le parc locatif
face à ce constat la reconduction des
mesures de protection des locataires
apparaît comme une évidence
et c'est bien ce qui nous est ici
proposé j'entends pourtant la tentation
du blocage pur et simple des loyers mais
comment souhaiter la mise sur le marché
locatif de davantage de logement tout en
mettant en péril les investissements que
cela implique pour les locataires les
propriétaires et comment exiger deux la
rénovation de leur bien sans leur donner
les moyens de revaloriser les loyers en
conséquence et en proportion des
économies d'énergie que cela implique
une idée qui peut paraître séduisante
donc mais qui dans les faits ne ferait
qu'accentuer le raréfaction des biens
mis à la location et freiner leur
rénovation entretenant ainsi le
déséquilibre entre le nombre de biens à
la location et une demande
conjoncturellement croissante
à l'inverse d'autres pourraient
regretter que nous ne laissions pas
libre cours au marché préférant faire
peser les hausses du coup du logement
uniquement sur les locataire
mais en plus de fragiliser ces derniers
cela reviendrait à accentuer des
situations d'impayés
alors non la situation exceptionnelle
que nous connaissons exige de partager
l'effort équitablement par une
régulation qui soit responsable et
solidaire
la question vous l'aurez compris n'est
donc pas d'établir une opposition
manichéenne et stérile entre locataire
et propriétaire les uns ayant besoin des
autres
elle est de protéger le pouvoir d'achat
de nos compatriotes tout en garantissant
au bailleur la capacité à réaliser les
investissements nécessaires au maintien
de leurs biens en location et dans des
conditions décentes
à cet égard la proposition qui nous est
faite aujourd'hui par notre collègue
Thomas Cazenave qui consiste donc à
plafonner l'augmentation des loyers
civils et commerciaux à 3,5% jusqu'au
début de l'année prochaine apparaît
comme la plus équilibrée ne rien faire
ce serait renoncé et si opposé
reviendrait à entériner une hausse
importante des loyers pour toutes ces
raisons et en cohérence avec les actions
que nous menons notre groupe votera bien
évidemment pour ce texte et continuera
tout au long de ce mandat agir en faveur
de l'accès un logement digne pour tous
et partout je vous remercie je vous
remercie
sur le vote de la proposition de loi je
suis saisie par le groupe renaissance
d'une demande de scrutin public le
scrutin est annoncé dans l'enceinte de
l'Assemblée nationale
la parole est à Monsieur Nicolas
maisonnet pour le groupe rassemblement
national
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le Président de la Commission
monsieur le rapporteur cher collègue
un mois deux navettes avec le Sénat
trois lectures en séance à l'Assemblée
nationale des heures de débat pourquoi
non pas pour discuter d'une réforme
profonde structurelle essentielle et
urgente que nous devons avoir en France
sur la politique de logement non
des heures de débat pour prolonger une
mesure aide qui évitera que dans deux
jours les prix des loyers explosent et
frappent de plein fouet non seulement
les foyers de nos concitoyens les plus
modestes mais aussi de nos TPE nos
artisans nos commerçants qui ont déjà
forte à faire avec les crises multiples
qui subissent et pour lesquelles le
gouvernement fait preuve d'une totale
impuissance alors si on doit accorder un
mérite un seul mérite à cette petite
proposition de loi c'est celui d'agir
comme le révélateur de ce qu'est la
gestion macroniste et les Français qui
nous regardent doivent là comprendre
pourquoi plus rien plus rien ne
fonctionne dans ce pays chers collègues
pourquoi les prix des loyers menacent de
s'envoler
parce que l'inflation s'envole et
pourquoi l'inflation s'envole en raison
des politiques que vous menez des
décisions que vous prenez insuffisante
pour ne pas dire inconséquente du vent
de la com et à la fin des résultats
désastreux on l'a dit et répéter la loi
pouvoir d'achat voter en 2022
était dès le départ indigente mal
calibrée loin très loin d'apporter les
réponses nécessaires aux enjeux et aux
crises que les Français traversent et
c'est si vrai qu'un député de la
minorité présidentielle s'est réveillé
un matin en sursaut in extremis pour se
courir le gouvernement avec ce test que
nous examinons aujourd'hui alors oui
nous examinons là un texte mineur mais
urgent qui aurait dû faire consensus
d'abord entre les deux chambres c'était
sans compter sur les sénateurs LR qui
ont fait le choix de s'en laver les
mains se réfugiant derrière des
arguments fallacieux toujours sur la
forme sans jamais dévoiler ce qu'il
pensait réellement sur le fond peut-être
la souhaitait-il au fond l'augmentation
des prix des loyers peut-être ont-ils le
souhait eux de défendre les intérêts des
foncières les plus voraces nul ne le
saura et puis il y a ceux ici à
l'Assemblée nationale sur les bancs de
la nupes qui veulent faire de cette
inflation leur miel sans doute pensant
en tirer un bénéfice électoral pensant
tromper les Français en leur disant
vouloir le gel voir la baisse des loyers
sachant très bien les conséquences
désastreuses que ces mesures irréalistes
auraient sur le logement et l'immobilier
sachant pertinemment que cela
détournerait les investisseurs de la
création de logements que cela
inciterait les propriétaires ne plus
louer ou à se tourner vers la location
de courte durée que cela dissuadorait
les petits propriétaires d'entretenir ou
rénover les que cela mettrait en
difficulté ceux qui ont économisé toute
leur vie pour se constituer un petit
patrimoine quand la démagogie confiné à
l'hypocrisie et aussinisme et le plus
incroyable c'est que tout au long de ces
débats de la nippesse vous avez passé
votre temps à donner des leçons moi je
vais vous dire si vous voulez défendre
les Français les plus modestes si vous
voulez qu'ils aient accès au logement
commencez par un vol logement sociaux
alors nous on rassemblement national
contrairement à la nupes qui fait du
refus du jeu démocratique ça marque de
fabrique nous allons prendre nos
responsabilités nous allons voter ce
texte qui ne règle rien de façon pérenne
mais qui va empêcher que les prix des
loyers augmentent dans des proportions
insupportables pour nos compatriotes
particuliers comme professionnel parce
qu'on veut protéger les locataires parce
qu'on veut protéger nos entreprises
parce que nous considère pas non plus
qu'il faille faire la guerre au petit
propriétaire nous allons voter ce texte
mais nous disons et redisons qu'il faut
des réformes structurelles sur tous les
sujets d'ailleurs mais pour ce qui nous
concerne ici sur le logement en premier
lieu et même sur l'aménagement du
territoire carlov ne va pas sans l'autre
il faut une grande réforme pour des
métropoliser déconcentrer rééquilibrer
les territoires il faut une grande
réforme pour traiter la question des
taux intérêts qui plombe l'accès la
propriété et nous souhaitons donner les
moyens à chaque Français de pouvoir
devenir un jour propriétaire il faut une
grande réforme pour inciter à la
construction et rétablir un équilibre
entre l'offre et la demande il faut une
grande réforme pour éviter qu'avec les
objectifs sur les DPE des millions de
logements sortent du parc locatif il
faut une grande réforme pour que soit
traité la question merci zone tendues
c'est ce que notre merci monsieur
la discussion générale est close
je mets au voile la proposition de loi
telle qu'elle résulte du texte voté par
l'Assemblée nationale en nouvelle
lecture je vous prie de bien vouloir
regagner vos places le scrutin est
ouvert
le scrutin est clos
voici le résultat du scrutin votant 161
exprimé 171 majorités
86%, 34 l'Assemblée nationale a adopté
[Applaudissements]